- I had this idea that if
we come to the fish market,
if we could find somebody to,
if we could buy some fish
or something interesting
and have somebody cook it for us,
this would be the ultimate fish
market experience in Sichon.
(reggae music)
Good morning everyone it's Mark Wiens.
I am in Sichon, in Southern
Thailand, Nakhon Si Thammarat.
(speaking in foreign language)
This morning we are at
a very local fish market
which is right next to the ocean.
And we're here to just walk
around and see what we can find.
I'm loving it.
We got here at about seven,
it's about 7:30 a.m. and we were--
- [Ying] Is that one boat coming?
- Oh have a boat coming right now.
Okay we got here about 7 a.m. and we,
I was almost disappointed
because all the trays are empty.
We thought they are cleaning up already.
But they have just told us,
an auntie has just told us
that the fish haven't arrived yet.
So they'll be coming in
about 30 minutes hopefully.
So we're here a perfect time.
This has to be one of the
most picturesque markets
I've ever been to in my life.
It is right next to the ocean,
just a friendly atmosphere,
just all local fishermen, the coconuts.
(reggae music)
How it works is that the
boats come up in the morning
and sometimes the family members will then
sell the fish from the fishermen.
And other times some of
the ladies at the market
they will come here and
buy some of the fish
and then resell them at the market.
And this is the first
boat in this morning.
They have a little
selection of different fish
and some crabs in there.
(woman shouting in foreign language)
I'll have some Patongko, one.
(woman speaks in foreign language)
Yeah.
(speaks in foreign language)
As we're waiting for the main
bulk of the fish to arrive,
we're gonna have some
snacks for breakfast today.
One of the classic
Thai-Chinese street snacks
to eat in the morning is Patongko
which are the fried donuts, savory donuts.
Grab a little bite like this.
Yeah, hot and fresh.
You got to eat them hot and fresh.
If they're like cold and
stale, they're not very good.
One of my favorite sweet
Thai dessert snacks
is called Khanom krok.
And they are making an
amazing version over here.
Really old style.
(speaks in foreign language)
You gotta, (speaks in foreign language)
This is by far the coolest Khanom krok
that I've ever seen in Thailand.
Her technique is amazing
and this is a ancient,
old, old style of making Khanom krok.
You got that really, the
piece of the iron griddle
and then she's adding in
the different mixtures
and even her spoon with the bamboo,
it's a piece of bamboo
made into a little spoon
where she dips in and then adds
that coconut milk to the little cakes.
It's awesome, absolutely
awesome and they're so friendly.
I've just been asking them
about their Khanom krok,
they don't add sugar but
it's just coconut milk.
There's two layers, the first
liquid batter is coconut milk
and a little bit of rice flour
and that's what holds it together.
And then the top layer of liquid
is just pure coconut milk.
Sometimes you'll see on
the streets of Thailand,
you'll see that they use a
lot of oil to oil the griddle
before they put in the
batter so it doesn't stick.
They say they don't use any oil
because they don't need oil
because of the coconut milk.
It's just all coconut milk,
it's so much coconut milk
that they don't need,
they don't even need oil.
And they make them into little cup shapes
and then they put them together as two.
So a little twin.
And normally you can, let me
find one that's really hot.
Oh yeah, this one feels like
it's right off the fire.
Look at that, if you can get
a really close-up look at that
you can just see how that's just like,
like thickened, reduced coconut milk.
Oh that's amazing.
Oh I think that's the best
Khanom krok I've ever had.
There's no sugar in it.
They give you a little packet
of sugar to eat on the side.
You can either pour it
on or you can just eat it
with no sugar and just rely on
that coconut milk for the sweetness.
The coconut milk itself has
a little bit of a sweetness,
it's also a little bit salty.
They've added some salt to the recipe
to add contrast and that just
kinda increases the flavor
of the coconut.
It amplifies the flavor of the coconut.
That's like coconut pudding
within a crunchy, smoky shell.
Outrageously good.
Here comes another boat in from the sea
and this is like a chain pulley device.
There's actually a motor
there to pull the boat in
from the ocean and unto the bank.
That looks like it's
been used a few times.
(reggae music)
(speaking in foreign language)
More and more of the
fishing boats are arriving
but we got hung up on
eating all those snacks
'cause they are so friendly and so nice
and just invited us to sit down and eat.
Today, for unpredictable reasons,
was honestly not the best catch.
Most of the local fishermen
only caught small fish,
handfuls of mackerel, and
a few crabs mixed within.
But part of the beauty of
visiting this local fish market
in Thailand is that it
isn't at all commercialized.
The fishermen are all from this village
and their catch isn't transported
to a bigger city or
sold at a bigger market.
But everything that's caught is sold
and consumed right within
this fishing community.
Oh Pla lai.
(conversing in foreign language)
We're trying to sort of talk
to some of the aunties here
and see if anyone will cook for us.
Hello.
- [Man] What is your name?
- Mark.
- What is your name?
- Yes.
What is your name?
- Dahot.
- Nice to meet you.
(hip hop music)
I just ended up on the
back of a motor bike
and we are going over to
auntie's house to cook some eel.
(speaking in foreign language)
(hip hop music)
- Try.
Try.
- Try, try.
(speaks in foreign language)
Let me just quickly
tell you what happened.
I don't even know if I can
explain the whole story.
But we're at the market, and
we actually started talking
with auntie who was selling eels.
I was just asking her how she cooked it
and she said, mix Pad
Phet, which is a stir-fry
with chili paste and lots of chilies.
And then we just kinda asked her
or Ying talks to her and all of a sudden,
I was on the back of a motorcycle
on the way back to her place
and she's making a dish
called Pla lai Pad Phet,
which is eel stir-fried
with all the chili paste in.
I can't wait to try it.
Cutting up the eel is a real art.
But she is doing it so expertly.
You have to cut out that big, thick bone
and then she's navigating
her way around it
and slicing the meat and then cutting it
into pretty small pieces.
But you can tell that she has
done this many, many times.
At this house they're also making kapi,
which is shrimp paste.
It's fresh shrimp paste that they're,
well, it's not fresh
because it has to leaven,
sort of ferment, to make it shrimp paste.
But they're making it right at home.
So this is homemade shrimp paste
and she's gonna include
some of it in the recipe
that she's making with the eel.
To make the spicy eel,
she first sauteed a bunch
of garlic in some hot oil
and then added in a heap of curry paste
which she had already
mixed with shrimp paste.
And let that sizzle in the oil
to release a massive amount of flavor.
She then tossed in the
chopped up pieces of eel
and stir-fried it until
all of the eel was coated
in luscious curry sauce.
(speaking in foreign language)
Finally, a good handful of fresh chilies,
some young green peppercorns,
and plenty of fresh holy basil,
all of which were picked
from right outside the house,
finished it off.
(speaking in foreign language)
The eel is finished and it's stir-fried.
They added in more chilies
and some green pepper.
And this is a piece, a little
piece of the eel, the meat.
Wow!
(speaks in foreign language)
That's delicious.
Eel is just so buttery
and melt in your mouth.
And then that's just coated
in so much curry paste
and shrimp paste, you can
taste the shrimp paste nicely.
And that's awesome that they make
the shrimp paste right here at home.
And that's spicy.
Oh that's good.
She's packing it now.
Into bags.
And we're gonna head
back to the fish market.
(reggae music)
I got my bags full of Pla lai.
The eel and they're gonna show
me some more eels back here.
(speaking in foreign language)
(Mark laughs)
(speaks in foreign language)
Bye bye!
- Bye bye!
- And we are off with a bag of eel.
(reggae music)
For the fish market, today
there wasn't a lot of big fish.
It was mostly small
fish, a lot of mackerel.
So I guess it really just
depends on what day you come.
You might see some bigger fish,
you might see some more interesting fish.
But today was just kind of small fish.
But that's cool!
This is real life.
This is the reality,
this is a local market.
They are selling fish just for people
within this neighborhood and
in this coastal community.
This is what I love seeing.
This is amazing.
(reggae music)
So we're gonna just drive around
and hopefully find somewhere to eat lunch
and eat that eel and then
just enjoy this area.
(reggae music)
We just stopped on the side of the road
because Ying spotted,
they're picking the coconuts.
But they're using monkeys.
Monkeys are up in the
trees and they're the ones,
the monkeys are picking the coconuts.
Boom! Here comes a coconut.
(speaks in foreign language)
Most of the coconuts in
this coconut field are all
old coconuts and so they're
picking them for coconut milk.
So you can't really, the water
in them doesn't taste so good
but I asked them if they
have some young coconuts
that I can buy.
According to NPR,
Thailand has been raising
and training monkeys to pick
coconuts for over 400 years.
And while there's some notable controversy
about the practice, in the short time
that I had the chance to watch,
I saw the owners handling their monkeys,
this particular monkey
who's name was Kaimuk,
with respect and as if they
were part of their family.
(reggae music)
(speaks in foreign language)
We've stopped off just
at a local restaurant.
There's not a lot of choices
for restaurants around here
but this looks like an amazing spot.
It's right next to the beach.
We have beach front tables.
(speaking in foreign language)
They have a few seats under shelter
in front of the restaurant
but this, this out here
on the beach is the real
beauty of the restaurant.
(reggae music)
The setting here could
not be more spectacular.
The biggest danger right now,
is that I'm like this far
away from a coconut tree.
So I better eat fast.
I'm gonna start with the kraprao neua
and this is beef
stir-fried with holy basil.
There's chilies in here,
there's onions she put
and also sliced up long beans.
And put this onto my rice, oh yeah!
The holy basil is really strong.
It's a little bit spicy.
You can taste the oyster sauce in there.
It's a little bit of a balance
between salty and a
little bit sweet as well.
Next up, these are the
tiny little shellfish
that, maybe they're tiny little clams,
I think they're tiny little
clams that she stir-fried up.
This was not really on
their menu that they cooked
but I saw them in the back there
and I asked them if they would cook them.
And then she just, like
graciously, cooked a plate for us.
And look at these little
guys, they're tiny.
And you just, I saw these
at the market as well.
So they did sell them at the market,
at the seafood market
earlier this morning.
Oh yeah!
Those are tiny but those are really good.
That's just a tiny, tiny little
bit of flavor in every shell
but the flavor that you
do get is wonderful.
These are like snack shells.
They're just sit here and
snack on them all day long.
Okay next up our Kai
jeow, this is an omelet.
Oh she put some onions
in here too, wonderful.
And I will add a little
bit of that Prik Nam Pla,
which is fish sauce and chilies.
It's one of the great flavors of Thailand.
It's crispy, it's salty.
The fish sauce gives it the
wonderful Thai uniqueness of it.
And then finally not forgetting the eel.
(speaks in foreign language)
Let me take out some of this.
There's some bones in here too
but you can see all of that, oh wow!
Look at how chunky and just
full of all those ingredients,
those herbs, there's lemongrass in there,
there's turmeric, there's
young pepper in there.
(woman speaks in foreign language)
(Ying laughs)
(Mark speaks in foreign language)
Alright, so with the eel, you gotta,
I'm not sure if there's any
bones in this bite or not.
Wow!
That eel is absolutely spectacular.
The eel itself just sorta
melts in your mouth.
It's so soft and buttery and fatty.
But then that curry paste
that it's fried with
they just, massive flavor it's,
you can taste the lemongrass,
the turmeric in there.
It's spicy.
Properly spicy.
I love the green peppercorns and also
you can taste the holy
basil in there as well.
(speaking in foreign language)
This is the type of community,
rural, countryside restaurant
that's so friendly, that the owner,
who is the auntie who's cooking comes over
just to not only say hi but to come over
and sit and chat and just hang
out while were eating here
and then that's the first
time we've ever met her.
Oh, the love, the community,
the friendliness of this
place is unbelievable.
These little shellfish
are addictively good.
They're so good,
but they're so small.
You just kinda slurp them down.
They're delicious.
That was an extremely satisfying lunch.
But there is one thing on my mind.
The only thing on my
mind after that lunch.
And it's in the back of the car.
(reggae music)
I've never opened a coconut
in this fashion before
but they have an up-pointed spear.
This is to, so you
don't fall on it I think
this piece of coconut but then you,
I don't know if I'll be able.
I'm gonna try using
this for the first time.
Actually I have an expert
who's gonna help me.
(speaks in foreign language)
He cut open that coconut a lot better
than I ever could have.
(speaks in foreign language)
That coconut is just filled with water.
There's so much in there.
Oh wonderful.
Oh it's kind of leaking out.
Got a hole in the shell.
(speaks in foreign language)
Oh yeah.
The coconut is starting to
get on the old side I think.
It's a little bit, has a little bit
of a fermented taste but it's really good.
It's sweet and refreshing.
Oh yeah, it almost has like a fizz to it.
Just gonna take a walk out onto the beach.
But that was a satisfying lunch.
And just take a look at this beach.
Just part of what makes
it, it's just how peaceful,
how relaxing, and how quiet,
and friendly this place is.
Lunch was good but I also
highly, highly enjoyed
walking around the market this morning.
Ying and I have met just in a,
we've only been here in
Sichon for a very short time
but we have already met so many,
so many friendly, genuine people.
This is really an amazing
coastal community.
I'm gonna end this video right now.
Thank you all very much for watching.
Please remember to give this video
a thumbs up if you enjoyed it.
Also I'd love to hear from you
in the comments section below.
And finally, if you're
not already subscribed,
click subscribe now, I'm gonna be sharing
with you lots more food and travel videos.
And thank you again for watching,
I'll see you on the next video.
Goodbye from Sichon, Thailand.